[Music]
where my mom really nailed it
and when i think a lot of moms and dads
miss it in this day
is she built self-esteem but not
delusion and held me accountable
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
he's a monster and when i say he's a
monster he's a monster and this this guy
is the definition of success definition
of multitasking the definition of an
entrepreneur
uh the definition of a gritty hustler uh
a guy i have a tremendous amount of
respect for
uh gary vaynerchuk is that this is going
to take the introduction is going to
take a long time
because he's getting into the show it's
been i got to set you up because
the big holding company is vaynerx and
vaynermedia is probably the biggest part
of it it's
i don't call it agency but it's more
than that it's also got vayner
productions gallery media group the
sasha group tracer
speakers vaynertown vaynercommerce he's
also a co-founder of vaynersports rezzy
empathy wines a very empathetic guy a
tremendous speaker
he's also got the podcast the gary v
audio experience he's
five-time best-selling author his uh his
social media goes of course
about 30 million followers gary vee
welcome to on brand
thanks donnie it's a real honor to be on
with you hope you've been well
i've been well and um you know before we
get into it i want to play a clip
of you on the big idea about 14 years
ago uh that was my old cnbc show for the
listeners don't ask who was a
all show about entrepreneurs long before
shaq shark tank or in the
entrepreneurial shows
and here's a 31 year old very feisty
gary vaynerchuk
you know too many people don't
understand sometimes you know
people are talking about what are you
doing now to me it's not about what
you're doing now it's about
where you're going you know i was a
young guy i'm still a young guy i want
to accomplish
crazy things and there's no way i'm
going to cash in i'm going to reinvest
with the people around me absolutely
it's it's hard you can't go wrong
betting on talent
no you want the difference between
staying small and getting big and
whatever you do in life
i just want to put this out there in
neon again is
it's the people stupid you invest in
people will always come back
gary that was seems like yesterday 14
years ago how come
i look so much [ __ ] older and you
look younger what do you two know
what the [ __ ] happened with that man we
both looked like we had a
good and aggressive 14 years uh i look
like a chai i look like my s
my the son of who i look like now um i
uh
i remember that show very vividly i
always
talk about that uh appearance quite a
bit because for the listeners here
to donny's point i'll say for him that
was the you know there was no business
shows that you wanted to be on more than
that show at the time and
i was very honored to be on it and you
know it's really funny
just listening to that clip real quick
it
scares me to think nothing's changed
from the feelings i just had the
chemicals
i feel like i'm still an extremely young
guy
i have a tremendous amount of ambition
um and you know experience matters for a
reason so
you get into this and i'm sure you feel
this way i think when you
have young raw talent you know there is
a level of conviction and confidence
that comes along with that that is
beautiful
and a lot of times your fresh eyes and
you're seeing things others can't
but there's an incredible amount of
value and pattern recognition
and reps and since that day to this
exact second
those 14 years make me feel really
ambitious about the next
14 years so i feel like i'm just getting
started also i don't know when that
stops
i don't know when it is but to your
point the combination
of what you call reps you know whether
10 000 hours or whatever
whatever it is with that kind of the raw
hustle ambition grit is a great combo
i got a great compliment last week i was
doing an interview for with that age and
they uh
they do a weekly interview with the
editor does online and i think you've
done in the past
and they said to me you know they're
really you know this donnie when you
were in the business you were a big
personality and you were and they were
really other than gary vee there are no
personalities today
and i was it was it was a real pleasure
and a real compliment being compared to
you but
where you blow by me in spades is that
you know i built a great company i built
an agency and it was an asian was one
business and that you have just had this
vision and you understood the
gary garyvee brand but you keep taking
it to new
places and i that to me is so impressed
me and what
because it's very easy you build
something and you stop you go this is
great but
you keep kind of you're on the cusp of
every next thing you just start your nft
business your
esports business and that's give me
where the kind of vision to where it's
like you're you're always about tomorrow
and it's always about what's next and
that's what drives peter
that is right um i think it comes from a
couple things
one one thing that i've realized about
myself recently unfortunately i'm ju i'm
glad i made it back on time i
had a funeral i had to go to of an
incredible woman by the name of barbara
siegelman who was
in essence my dad's great aunt through
marriage
and this was the family that when we
came from the soviet union that really
took us under their wing and
americanized us and helped us in a lot
of ways
and you know i was just with my mom and
dad and sister
us kind of core you know my brother as a
young family wasn't able to make it and
i was just thinking as i was looking at
my folks because
that was kind of like the rich american
family side of the family right
you know i remember the first time i saw
a car phone like
in the car was in a jaguar that barbara
siegelman had right
and this is when like we were really
lower
middle class and um
it was funny when you just asked that
question how i just put the two things
that happened today
together i think the biggest thing that
makes me keep going
is how little i like the fruits
of professional success from a financial
standpoint to do things with it i prefer
the game
it's the process not not the [ __ ] not
the stuff that's it right i love when
you give speech i love when you give
speeches to young people
you start don't [ __ ] tell me about
what you're going to buy or what you're
going to do
it's really big for me and honestly i
want to find a little bit of balance
because there's people that genuinely
love the craftsmanship of a great watch
or
or uh having a yacht or you know i don't
want to demonize
enjoyment for me enjoyment is having the
means to go to every playoff game of the
knicks and jets if i want to so
i have things i'm passionate about as
well but the real answer to your
question
is it's more fun to me to
and i just am coming out of one from
february 12th
to may 12th actually i was going at it
at a level that i probably hadn't gone
at it in a while because i was building
this nft project
while vayner x and vayner media are
exploding it is our era it is our time
we're in the pre-dawn
of our decade for sure you know we've
built a large company but
now the world's really coming to our
level and our style
of advertising and
and i just you know and it was getting
nicer out and
new york and covid's kind of like you
know we all know we're living through
and a lot of people are golfing
and sailing and doing some stuff and i
was happy
and i realized my god it is my hobby my
great
hobby is innovating new things
and my great talent is having intuition
around new things and you know it's
turning out to create a unique career
yeah no the vaynermedia is interesting
for those who who don't know
gary you kind of built your bones in
social media and as a digital guy
and you backed as opposed to traditional
agencies that says we need to figure out
the digital thing
you did the other way around you've got
blue chips clients now as blue as they
get
i have to congratulate you on a spot
that i saw you did recently [ __ ]
brilliant for pepsi
about you know set to annie uh this one
will come out tomorrow and i'm not gonna
do it justice but it's
it's basically showing all the things
all the kind of disgustingly human
relatable things we do drink from each
other's things sweat on each other and
that
we're back doing it now and yeah give me
the quick story because you were
a little i was an outsider in my
business also and you know i was kind of
the renegade and nobody liked me and i
was
you know i was disrupting before i knew
what disrupting was and you've built an
entire
empire on that so give me the little the
beginning of vaynermedia and how it's
just exploded
you know i i'm a big fan of
self-awareness i think if you're
listening to this show
this is actually a very good topic
because i just have a good enough sense
of who you are if you're listening to me
on donnie's show like you're in a pocket
of interest
ambition curiosities i got to tell you
self-awareness is a monster that isn't
talked about enough
i had built this very large business
which is what gave me the luxury to be
on donnie's big show at the time
for my dad this wine business i did in a
very contemporary way
email website and the youtube show which
is really revolutionary at the time
and i started getting attention from
silicon valley
i became an early investor in
twitter and facebook and tumblr and
really found myself deep in silicon
valley web 2.0
and i started having crazy life
experiences meeting barack obama and
talking about social media
spending dinners with mark zuckerberg
like just
real i mean like going from a liquor
store in springfield and like you know
24 months in these rooms that i'm in
and i remember not only being in the
room donnie but feeling
because i would stay in a very narrow
combo it was communication right it
wasn't like we were talking about health
care
sure we weren't talking about the solar
system we were talking about my game
and my marketing to build my dad's store
i built a three
million dollar almost four million
dollar business to a 60 million dollar
business
with no money on just finding every
angle that was of the second
and the kpi was a business result not a
headline
not a not a metric not a report it was
business
and i remember not only being in the
room but i remember feeling
like the sharpest tool in the room yeah
and this was sharp tools
and so i just i didn't go crazy i didn't
go egotistical i didn't think i was
anything special
i just had a really calm year with
myself in 2009-10
saying okay this is something what am i
going to do about it
and i remember i leaned into another
thing of mine which is not as obvious
given my energy but
i really from both of my parents and my
upbringing
have a level of humility and patience
that's unique
and i said you know what i've got this
talent why don't i build
a deaf i'm a star wars guy i'm going to
build a communications death star
for myself this is where you don't even
know this part of the story
what's really unique about vayner is
i don't have a dream of selling it to a
holding co with a huge turnout
you get offers all the time don't you
all the time yeah what's the matter
what's the multiples today
i mean you know i mean the things i'm
getting offered are crazy because
they're multiple on revenue not on
ebitda
multiples on what's the multiple revenue
they're giving you now
i could probably get you know i've been
offered something in the ballpark of
five to seven on revenue versus 12 to 18
on eba
that's crazy but what what i'm really
focused on is i'm building this for
myself you know rezzy
was a 200 million dollar ex at the amex
consolation bought empathy 18 months in
i did something with k-swiss sneakers
that really worked i sold 40 million
dollars worth of nfts donnie
in three weeks i want you in two minutes
to our audience explain because you're
doing something
different on nfts and in terms of gary b
friends explain to nft
explain your nfts nft
is owning a digital asset that's exactly
what it is and i get
why you know in the same way that i told
my friends we're all going to date
online
in 1997 they thought that was crazy or
and you you you innovated understanding
you know tell tell the viewers at home
not every business thought they needed a
website
back in the day they just didn't they
didn't think they needed it of course
they didn't you know and definitely not
a social
uh social network account yeah um so
i believe nfts will be omnipresent
if you have a child in your life that
plays fortnite
roblox mind crap share excuse a
minecraft excuse me or
or if you remember just 10 years ago
people spending real money buying sheep
on farmville people buy virtual currency
and that's going to grow
you know it's not just about the art and
the collectible ownership like a
painting or a sports card
what's crazy about nfts is that they
have the ability to have smart contracts
underneath them
so you can buy let me give you an
example you could buy a john mcenroe nft
it's an image of an artist drawing
johnny mac but what you're really buying
is underneath the image it's there's a
contract that says you get a one-hour
hitting session with johnny mac
so you have this all of a sudden yeah
correct and what you're going to see is
every ticket
every membership all of it is going to
turn into this digital asset this nft
and people are going to look at each
other's nfts the way they look at each
other's photos
on social what i did with v friends was
i've been infatuated with intellectual
property
my whole life you can watch a hundred
videos on youtube where i talk about i'm
building vayner and i'm going to buy ip
and i'm going to run it through vayner
vayner's being built for me
we have clients today but eventually
we'll have clients
and then half the company will work on
my owned and operated businesses like
i've done with rezzy
and empathy i thought i was going to buy
the smurfs i thought i was going to buy
starter jacket i thought i was going to
buy some of these things
then nfts came along and i said wait a
minute i'm going to start my own
so i built my own power rangers my own
care bears my own
scooby-doo they're called v-friends
they're all the things that i talk about
empathy patience ambition work ethic in
character form empathy elephant patient
panda
and i've sold these nfts but what i did
was i added another thing that i've been
wanting to do
since i was overly affected by south by
southwest years ago i've always wanted
to throw a super conference
so along with the v friends that people
bought donnie
you get a three-year ticket to something
called v-con that i'm gonna throw once a
year
where i'm just gonna have a but you'll
probably get an email from me in a
couple months saying hey don do you want
to moderate a thing or do you want to do
that like i'm going to throw
a smorgasbord coachella meets
south by meets davos entrepreneurial
you know innovation uh summit once a
year
and then above that there was about two
percent of the tokens that had silly
things like come and sit and watch a
knicks game with me play me and ping
pong
have dinner with me so i was trying to
show because you started seeing a lot of
influencers and celebrities come to the
space
of nft and just put out draw put out an
image
and that was that's not the real thing
there we're gonna buy homes
we're gonna buy this is a ledger we're
gonna transact
people are gonna buy businesses like
literally people are going to nft their
homes and sell the nft that comes with
the home
you don't need me to tell you this but
you know your nft business is going to
out monetize all your other businesses
combine 10x
well i'll tell you why the thing that is
just completely have
and and i do happy i'm trying to learn
how to pinch myself and smell a rose a
little bit more
because i've always been i don't like it
i don't but it also helps me not get too
low when things are bad but i'm just
kind of that way but nonetheless
donnie here's what's nuts in the
contract of my nft
and what i recommend any listener that
goes through it you can put a royalty
component
so there is a 10 royalty one percent i'm
giving to charity nine percent for me
on every secondary transaction i
i i didn't make i didn't make seventy
two thousand dollars the first
seven years i worked for my dad you know
per year not obviously
sure i i made 72 000 in the last 24
hours
on the royalties of my nfd
you know it is crazy i said to my
brother when i kind of clicked
me in february i said you know george
lucas launched star wars as an nft and
then made the movies
he'd probably be the richest man on
earth today he would have never sold it
to disney
because the royalties on all that
secondary collectibles
is just mind-boggling so how do i if i'm
a a pepsi client or i'm a
cri a craft heinz client or everything
and i'm buying vaynermedia and
the very thing that i'm talking to you
about is your
vision about the next thing how do you
keep your
how do you keep one foot on home base to
make sure like like i i
i keeping up with you on an interview is
difficult
so how do i as a client you're building
all these things
how does each things continue to stand
and flourish as
the next kind of shiny toy is the thing
i don't mean that in a
no i got it you know you mean in a good
way yeah uh you uh
this is where i get to give you a
compliment back to the clip
it's the people stupid amen amen right
you know
lisa buckley's and claude's and mark
yodkins and
and you know katie sagans and lisa
buckley's and
rob and wanda it's it's i'm at a place
now
13 years in where i'm sitting with you
know we've got
globally probably 13 1400 employees
um but there's and you know this better
than anybody
there there's right now i would say
there's their
47 52 people you know that
like are the company right and i've
never
had you're catching me at a great time
i've never had
a crew like this not only are they
all exceptional not only am i better at
understanding the industry and what is
needed to be successful
but my my continuity feeling towards
them
aka do i think that in my top 40
executives the ryan harwood
sarah baumann's avery's gabby's
that you know do i think i let me just
give you the math
of the 40 top people i think run the
company today allen's
parkers of the world i think 80
are here in a decade that's crazy yeah i
had the same thing all right the same
thing it was just
and that's why you won and that's why
i'm going to win and that's what always
wins
because you know what real quick donnie
for everybody who's trying to build
different kind of companies
think of it as an offensive line in
football if you keep the same guys
together for five years in a row
they know everything about each other
you know and when you're constantly
switching guys out it's
sorry i i remember i didn't think it was
a fair fight we went in for new business
because we had this swat team that just
like we could finish each other
like it was just we weren't inventing
every we just knew it we knew what we
had we knew
it was a dynasty and you built this up
how do you um
how do you deal with equity how do you
deal with making people feel like
they're owners of a company
you know it's it early on i had a very
tough challenge i'll be very naked here
i started the company with my brother
and aj who's remarkable and
i was 33 he was 22 and we decided to go
50 50.
my belief when i started being her was i
would do it in five to six years
he would then kind of i would groom him
and he would kind of run it and i would
be on to my next
michigan because you know i like the
action i knew that about myself
my brother has crohn's disease and about
so we were exploding
from 40 to 300 people in an hour
and like literally in two years it was
just a lot and my brother
is far he has so many more skills than
me
um and but the the concept of managing
people's feelings
was extremely like not overly exciting
for him and you know this
the the ad business is the people
business
really i think i'm in the hr business
and then we happen to do all this other
stuff and
he came to me and said i want to do
something else hence how he did
vaynersports
so i was in this very curious spot with
equity where i was already
not in a place where i to this day i
don't feel like i have
as much of the company as i'd like to
and so the way the way i've done that is
by building out all these other
businesses so for example
my co-founders in empathy wines started
as interns a decade ago
at vayner right these are gentlemen who
literally made
who became millionaires as partners with
me and so what i'm tr what i'm trying to
do donnie and what i've been doing is
hey
i've created a very aggressive bonus
pool for the top people b
uh most of these people and why i think
i have 80 retention which is over a
decade which is a ludicrous statement
it's ridiculous i know that for
everybody who's listening
is because of those 40 people most of
them have had a conversation with me of
like look
i'm doing a lot of things in my life uh
the guy who's gonna have equity and be
friends andy
k started as an intern on my content
team he's now the president of beef
friends
he's gonna it's gonna change his life
yeah i just tripled this out double this
double and a half his salary from
vaynermedia to be
friends so i think it's about it's not
about
competing with a holding company that
might give you fractions of shares
sure it's about actually making them
feel they're invested by actually
actually where they really really have
really meaty stuff is the key
is the secret sauce at the end of the
day the 30 million followers that you
have out there that basically ensures
everything you do has a kickstart to it
the uh the secret to this success is how
i built the 30 million followers from
scratch
good answer right right donny it's the
fact that i knew
i know two core things and it's very
advertise oriented
when you think about advertising
understanding distribution
where the human's intentions are and
understanding what creative goes into
that to provide a victory
is the game right that was television
radio outdoor and print
for a very long time direct mail
it is completely fragmented as you know
at this point so i think
what works for me i'll give an example
with v friends when i really talk about
it in three years
people are going to ask me questions of
why i left so much economics on the
table on the initial launch
so as remarkable and astonishing as the
number i threw out 40 50 million
depending on how ethereum's moving
and what it's like which is just you
know bonkers even for me i
i'm i'm stunned and flattered by that
success but understood it would happen
you know when i talk about 724 000 in
secondary sales in the last
24 hours many of these people who've
resold one of my tokens have made more
money on that token than i made
what i understood a long time ago is if
you're talented enough
to know what to do with the 49 of the
relationship
that you have with every individual on
earth and you're able to provide that
other individual
51 of the value you will be in an
incredible power spot your whole life
and i think what i've done uniquely
different than the far majority of
people that have come along over the
last 15 years trying to build a brand on
the internet
is there's two ways to really win
entertainment
or education entertainment comes in a
lot of shapes and sizes
entertainment is being very attractive
and being a model
on linked on instagram it could be being
you know
funny in skits on youtube or dancing
there's a million ways to do it
uh education comes in a lot of ways we
see as well on linkedin and many others
where you're talking about expertise
for me i've played a third kind of
little subtle gear
an obsession to making sure that every
person that comes in
gets more value than i get which has led
to very little asking
and a lot of giving my best [ __ ] away
for free
at scale for a decade and a half
and it's and i think that's the secret
to what i do
and i think that's going to always be my
strength because i know what to do with
my 49
yeah you always understood look even
simple advertising traditional
advertising you got to give the consumer
something
i always said you got to teach them you
got to make them laugh you got to give
you can't
you got to get and what's interesting is
your approach to business is very much
your approach to motivational speaking
and everything that you
you giving you're not a philanthropist
because you're you're a capitalist at
the same time but you understand that
one of the bedrocks of capitalism or at
least your bedrock
has been empathy and altruism and giving
so when you're giving a speech yes
you're making money from the speech but
what is turning you on is that you're le
you're giving nuggets and you're
that that's what is that's what drives
you it's a tremendous observation
i actually believe that
being selfish around you know what makes
you happy
triggers the ability to then be selfless
at scale which then creates selfish
you know results you know i i think
that's exactly right for me
i i just don't understand the concept of
being transactional or trying to win the
short term my dad actually used to be
pretty frustrated with me
in the way that i negotiated but what i
explained to him
was dad yes i understand that i probably
could have gotten that bottle of wine
and by the way when it's a bottle of
wine you're getting 500 cases there's
real economics when you're leaving
a dollar on the table right but i said i
said dad listen
i've watched you since i was 14 this is
now maybe when i'm 24. i'm like i've
been watching for the last 10 years
which is maybe from 14 to 17 you
wouldn't let me in the big meetings but
by 17 i was in these meetings i go look
you're a gangster you're a [ __ ]
gangster negotiator
but you're squeezing the [ __ ] out of
your suppliers
for everybody every time and then
they're not gonna go the extra distance
for you
and donnie what i really started seeing
happening because i'm a very observant
kid is
they started the numbers i started
realizing people were coming in and
starting price was higher to my dad
because they were expecting yeah and i
said dad
and we were in the liquor business where
you have to buy from the same suppliers
you can't go you know it's not like
every other business
you're mandated by the state of which
people you can work with by liquor laws
so
i took a different approach and i've
always left something on the table
for my suppliers and then with my
consumers my audience
i mean i'll be honest with you i hate
when i'm asking for something i have a
new book coming out in november
i don't love the promotion of that book
i'm not against it i'm a salesman i'm a
capitalist to your point
but i love the equity building of not
asking for anything
and the longer you hold your breath the
better you're going to do on your ask
yeah yeah what what is that if i said to
you because
you you immigrate over with with your
family at three years old
queens you come from um russia
um you're living eight people in one
room
yep you look back now and there's a lot
of people who start at the bottom but
not a lot of people make it where you
what if i tap you on the shoulder i'm
sitting next to you on the subway and
i'm going gary
what what how how how'd this all happen
ridiculously good mothering
love that 100 like you know it's donnie
do you know what's funny
the reason i think i can play it humble
and also don't get too high or too low
or
i'm very happy promoting and
self-promoting
is i actually think it's a bigger
indicator to my parents than to me
i feel like gary vee gary vaynerchuk is
the byproduct of tamara
and sasha vaynerchuk the byproduct of
the american dream
especially in the 70s 80s 90s and 2000s
and really on forever
it's still very much there i
i what happened was i had a mother who
built enormous self-esteem which is
imperative
i had that but she but donnie i'll tell
you and i don't know if you had this
with your mom
where my mom really nailed it and where
i think a lot of
moms and dads miss it in this day is
she built self-esteem but not delusion
and held me accountable i think what we
have now
is non-accountable delusional
self-esteem 100 trophies for showing up
yeah and you kind of get then kids grow
up and they get insecure because they
realize it was all fake
yeah whereas with my mom she would be
happy to smack me in my ass or even my
face
if i went out of line she also really
really allowed me to breathe i was a bad
student
and then and then so it was great
parenting and then it was circumstance
you know when you're born at the bottom
there's an inherent animalistic
need to climb and i also got to hone my
skills i was born in the
i was growing up in new jersey in the
80s so lemonade stands car wash
shoveling snow outside for 10 hours a
day unwatched
unsupervised the streets taught me and
the baseball card boom i learned my
craft
and by the time i was 22 coming into my
dad's business
i was ass and i mean this when i say
this by the time i walked in at 22 i was
a 16-year veteran of business
i've been doing business every day of my
life trying to sell something trying to
build something
so i think natural talent meets
circumstance
um and that's really what i am i'm a
nature nurturer byproduct like most
people are and it just kind of quote
unquote worked out for me
what i love about every just about every
one of your business philosophies
and every kind of instinct that you have
and every philosophy
is about the human condition it it it
that that is what you so
understand and he starts with
self-awareness also but as i listen to
your speeches and every one of your
philosophies
it starts with understanding flesh and
blood and humanity
you're behaviorist and that's what i
find so fascinating about all
speaking of human though one thing a
million-dollar billion dollar question
please
you get up at five you work out you work
from a you know seven in the morning to
eleven at night you got two kids how do
we do that
yes first of all i wake up at seven and
work
out and and more and more i i get a ton
of sleep
you know i think it's about um for me
it's
compartments right it's all in or all
out
that's works for me right so now
now my fathering explodes because
this virtual world yeah is the greatest
mitzvah for me of all time
the fact that everyone's now being
conditioned to do a zoo meeting
uh there's not a what a gift what a gift
yeah it's
what a gift what a gift and so for me
it's prioritizing
it's being checked out on the weekends
it's doing things
it's you know you know i'm a byproduct
of a dad that worked all day a lot of us
are
that still happens a lot and vice versa
moms that work all day
i i don't find it overtly you know
challenging
it's just about prioritizing and
actually i'll give you the real answer
for a lot of parents
it's not over judging yourself and
beating yourself up too many parents
miss one thing and they think they're
this horrible person
kids are resilient we remember the
things
not always the missed things and as long
as you try and have good intent
most things will work out i i had the
greatest parents the greatest dad in the
world who all he did was work but i
i had the best dad because i knew i
still came first i never counted what he
wasn't at
i remember and with my kids i had the
advantage i sold my company young uh
i actually regret it i i listen to you i
get jealous i get because i
i was at my space where you are now i
was king of the
i own the [ __ ] industry i know
michael jordan at the time i
i couldn't like they were coming at us i
was telling clients go [ __ ] them so i
mean the very
the basic thing and i the reason i sold
was
i don't you solved this problem i didn't
have the vision here i would walk into a
three-hour meeting i knew i was gonna
end in 30 seconds and i was bored
i was bored with my success i felt i had
won the game
i felt that you know what's funny i
lived that same life no but you've
solved it you've solved it
by creating new mountains but and i
created new i went into tv i did these
other things but yeah
i felt like i won you know we were
agents of the year i toured
five years where i was making a ton of
money because you did i didn't sell
because of a and i say to people
don't ever say you can't go visit your
money sell of course you're ready to do
something else
you know the mail oh i got this number
great you'd be [ __ ] miserable
somebody
somebody could give you five billion
unless otherwise you could buy the jets
so that might make it
make work that's the only reason you're
gonna monetize it only one but
you know that's a terrible mistake
people make and you don't do it for that
reason and i
was bored and the other thing i found
really difficult i wonder how you deal
with this as an alpha male
past a certain age being in a service
business is really hard
you really you're sitting across the
table from a
you know an advertising director that
you wouldn't hire nine levels below i
don't mean the word levels below you but
you wouldn't
even hire at your company there's not a
meeting
there's not a meeting i'm in that i
don't think i have more capability than
the ceo of the company of the meeting
so how do you now human patience
humility
knowing that i'm eating crow in this
situation
is actually the thing that's going to
make me win the whole ball game
it's i i convert that meeting not into
i'm in the ring and having the fight in
the main event i converted into i'm in
the gym
eight weeks before the main event
putting in the work so this
even what may look like a big meeting
and a big pitch
i mean dying to be very frank i felt
that way from the day i started
when i didn't even have the ws in the
industry to your point i've enjoyed
winning and being successful in this
industry because i like it i like a lot
of the people but it does have an
establishment as both you and i have
lived there is an establishment and
being anti-establishment
it's one more rep it's another sit up in
the gym it's another 45 minute hitting
the bag session
because i'm getting dangerously close to
having that
past the baton moment where it will
thrive
without me it will i will still be able
to stay very close to it very much like
i've
you know i've had an incredible rep at
this with my dad's wine business yeah
i'm still
very much intertwined there and i'll do
the same with vayner whenever that
time's right and
and i just know that it's worth it
eating that crow
one last question and then uh
observation on my end uh i asked this of
everybody but i'm most interested to
hear from you
what is the garyvee brand that's a great
question
i actually think the garyvee brand is
executed on something i believe in
which is every brand is actually
consumed differently at the consumer
level than people realize
right i you know people think nike state
doesn't stand for just do it it means
something different for people
everywhere so for i think for a lot of
people
it's work ethic grind that hustler thing
i think for
for an emerging group of people it's
whoa this dude is really pushing
kindness and empathy
and patience and these very grandma
virtues and he's making them cool that's
neat
for other people it's innovation and
seeing around corners
to me believe it or not donnie i don't
spend a lot of time thinking about it
what i think about is doing the best
things i can and hoping that
the other person on the other side
consuming it if they choose to
extracts some sort of value out of it
for me it's
it's for the way i see it within myself
it's
the obsession of the process your brand
i'm going to break it down for you your
brand is about giving
and in its essence whether it's giving
your intellectualism in terms of
motivation whether it's understanding
the dynamic consumer dynamic and you're
49 51
you have taken everything by given
everything
and it's a really interesting thing
about and i really enjoy i have to tell
you as kind of an elder statesman as a
guy who maybe passed
i've so enjoyed and impressed what
you've done over the last 15 years or so
i you know you were kind of a punk on my
show you know you had that wine business
you know yeah
i was like oh here's this guy he's kind
of but but i knew there was something
special but
just watching your career and watching
what you're doing now i know it's just a
good beginning
and i remember i always used to laugh
for those in the owners that don't know
that your one goal
is to buy the new york jets and i go
okay and more than ever after spending a
half hour so with you today
i do think that's a i don't know what
the johnsons are thinking but i think if
anybody can pry it away from
you keep doing it man keep fighting keep
kicking keep scratching
and keep setting a good example for
everybody cheers to you and thank you
for having me on it it's an honor stay
right buddy bye everyone
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you